- You've also said that The Matrix
may be one of your more
favorite AI-related movies.
Can you elaborate why?
- Yeah, it is one of my favorite movies.
And it's because it represents
kind of all the things I think about.
So there's a symbiotic relationship
between robots and humans, right?
That symbiotic relationship
is that they don't destroy us,
they enslave us, right?
But think about it.
Even though they enslaved us,
they needed us to be happy, right?
And in order to be
happy, they had to create
this gritty world that they
then had to live in, right?
That's the whole thing or premise.
But then, there were humans
that had a choice, right?
Like you had a choice to stay
in this horrific, horrific world
where it was your fantasy's
life with all of the anomalies,
perfection but not accurate.
Or you can choose to be on your own
and like have maybe no
food for a couple of days,
but you were totally autonomous.
And so I think of that, and that's why.
So it's necessarily us being enslaved,
but I think about us having
this symbiotic relationship,
robots and AI, even if
they become sentient,
they're still part of our society
and they will suffer just as much as we.
- Just as us.
And there will be some kind of equilibrium
that we'll have to find,
some symbiotic relationship.
- Right, and then you have the ethicists,
the robotics folks, that are
like, no this has got to stop.
I will take the other pill in
order to make a difference.